hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well a very
considerable portion of Posadas speech
in the symposium and you might say the
main thrust of it the main point of what
he's getting at concerns the
intersection of two important matters
one of which has to do with with laws
with legal regimes and we're going to
talk about the meaning of what law is
here because it's a little bit broader
than what we wet you know modern
Westerners think of as law unless we're
thinking in all sort of societal terms
and he's also talking about something
that gets translated as the love of
youths Petr Ostia in Greek literally
meaning the love of young boys but he
has something different in mind you know
something which wouldn't begin with with
just youths in the sense of boys but go
into adolescence there's there's a lot
of discussion in there about you know
why all these sorts of things should be
outlawed actually in his his view but
he's interested in how these legal
regimes in these different Greek
Commonwealth's or city-states how they
deal with this feature of ancient Greek
culture which had been around for quite
some time this notion of the beloved
and lover relation where the lover is
somebody older and the beloved is
somebody younger now he's dealing with
it exclusively within the context of
male male relations but there's no
reason why we couldn't read this speech
as applying to issues like the age of
consent in our own time now po science
is not making some sort of you know
blanket apology for this practice as a
matter of fact if you read his his
speech you'll see that he wants to
restrict it you know to a much narrower
range of people than the ones who are
allowed to engage in it in his his City
and indeed in the rest of Greece but
he's going to outline some some
different legal positions on this I said
that when we're thinking about law here
Greek you know Nomos we have to think a
little bit more broadly than what we
often might have in mind which is a law
right there's there's a law about this
or a law about that the Greeks had laws
in their other city-states governing
particular forms of behavior so there
could be a la you know forbidding
adultery for example or a law pertaining
to how much you can sell grain for at
what time in what place to what people
those are very specific laws what he has
in mind by law authors there's two
things we want to keep in mind one is
he's talking about law in the singular
but he really means it in the plural but
also in a different kind of singular
think of it as a legal regime a way in
which the laws articulate a whole range
of behaviors expectations penalties
what's allowed what's not allowed but
you know the Greek word no most doesn't
just mean a written law that that's down
somewhere that's being enforced in a
very definite way it also means
something like custom so you know the
mores would be another way of thinking
about this the you know the social
expectations about how things ought to
go the
might not be written down eventually
over time they will get written down but
that's not a necessity at the time that
he's talking but and we'll see why now
pause audience is a resident of Athens
he's actually the lover of Agathon and
the whole speech that he's making here
may in fact be as many commentators have
pointed out rather self-interested he's
trying to make an exception for himself
and you know justify his own behavior
well well d legitimating that of
practically everybody else involved in
it but he is engaging in some really
interesting although fairly crude legal
analysis or analysis of other other
political regimes he's engaging in some
comparative ethnography we could say at
least within the realm of hel Oz or you
know the greek-speaking world so he's
going to talk about other Greek
city-states as having simple and
straightforward laws simple and
straightforward ways of understanding
this male male relationship in which the
lover is older the beloved is somebody
who's in his adolescence and you know
how is this going to be viewed by by the
populace and by those who are involved
in it so in many respects is sort of
like the three bears you know Goldilocks
goes in and it's too hot or too cold or
too soft or too hard and there's always
something that's just right pops
audience is going to say Athens is just
right in in large part because it
doesn't take a simple straight forward
stance towards it both of these stances
are actually going to turn out to be bad
bad not necessarily in a moral sense but
bad in the sense that look it's just too
much too extreme it's not actually
suited well for for the kind of people
that Athenians are it is suited well for
the kind of people that we're talking
about here so he talks about Alice and
boy Tia you know these are sort of seen
as a backwoods you know hillbilly areas
it in Greece places where the people are
not as well developed I'll review
passage describing what's going on there
in in those places the lover is indulged
if the lover sees somebody and they want
to pursue them seduce them have sex with
them they get to do so and and even to
the extent of being able to force
themselves upon the younger person
without their consent and why is this
well Pausanias is going to say those
people are rather inarticulate I'll come
back to that in a moment the other
extreme it is ionia which is actually
under the Persian rule and the Persians
don't go for this sort of thing at least
you know the the bulk of Persian culture
there you know we're going to be a few
exceptions here and there but the
Persians really are not that keen on
this sort of thing and the ionians you
know except they're sort of point of
view so the love of youth is considered
to be disgraceful it's considered to be
an aberration it's not something you're
supposed to be engaging in why is that
well Pausanias has a very interesting
answer they hate freedom this might be
transposed into discussions in our own
day I leave that open to think about you
know those who who and want to put
repressive laws in place they just heat
other people's freedom maybe there's a
little bit more to this so let's go back
now before we go to Athens and you know
the just right place and let's look at
his discussion of these unfortunate
inter tick ulit buoyancy says in Ellison
booty and wherever the people are
naturally inarticulate wherever the ham
not really developed intellectually or
or in terms of the Arts in terms of you
know a way of life that's that's got a
lot of nuances to it so this is probably
applied to Sparta as well he says it's
def it's been definitely ruled that it
is right for the lover to have his rate
his way nor does anyone older young
presume to say that it's wrong nobody's
going to stand up for the one who's
being pursued there's a well that's just
the way it goes right why the idea being
he says to save themselves from
depleted with the young men for their
favors which is rather difficult for
lovers who are practically dumb so it's
precisely because they're inarticulate
that those city states allow these
people to have license and to impose
their will rather brutally upon the
young object of their sexual desires so
you know plus audience is saying that's
not good we don't want that sort of
thing going on he's not making an
apology for that he's just saying see
that's how badly off those particular
peoples are now he's got a longer
discussion of what's going on under the
Ionians and also incursio itself he says
in ionia and many other countries under
oriental ruler you know eastern role the
Persian rule under the Great King as the
Greeks call them the very same thing is
held to be disgraceful why because they
think it will not only have love but
also a philosophy and sport of you know
competitive sports on account of the
despotism the the condition of having a
tyrant and everybody else essentially
being slaves under which they live so
because they don't have any experience
of genuine freedom they're not really
sure what they're missing out on they do
know that they're they're afraid of
freedom and this sort of behavior is
likely to lead to exercises of freedom
not just freedom of the sense of license
getting to do whatever that what you
want to but rather it's going to lead to
a more substantive mode of freedom in
which genuine friendships develop and he
gives some examples here he says it
doesn't suit the rulers for their
subjects to engage in high thinking
that's philosophy or staunch friendship
and fellowship which love more than
anything is likely to be get those who
sees that power here in Athens learn the
same lessons from bitter experience for
it was the might of a risk to get tones
love and harmonious friendship that
brought their reign tuna and Athens had
its own
chira knees and you know tyrants
generally this is actually quite true
tyrus and totalitarian societies want to
keep people from developing fully as
human beings because when they do it's
rather unpredictable and they tend to
say things like well you know maybe you
don't need these tyrants in place maybe
we can live a different way so it says
wherever the law in acts that it is
wrong wrong across the board to yield to
the lover you may be sure that the fault
lies with the Legislature's the ones who
are in charge that is the saints due to
the oppression of the rulers and the
servility of their subjects so not only
do the rulers come down on them you know
and try to control everything the the
subjects themselves the people who are
in that they also replicate that by you
know keeping that Norman place and when
they see something like that happen oh
that's bad don't do that sort of thing
so they kind of deserve each other house
audience would say now we have the too
hot too cold or too strong to weak and
now we have Athens and Athens is in the
the realm of the just right not dm's
there we go athens evans has more
complex laws and that's what makes them
confusing whenever we have a difficult
subject to deal with something that's
very important because most important
subjects that deal with your social life
and how we behave tend to be rather
complex and when we're dealing with
these rather complex subjects we need
equally complex laws we need equally
complex systems of rules and norms and
the ways in which we evaluate and
understand things we need that sort of
thing in place because if we're
simple-minded we're going to go wrong so
Thomas Omnius says look there's a lot of
paradoxes that arise and we're going to
do a whole video on the paradoxes of
love that are revealed in the attitudes
that people have we can say you know if
we want to boil it down here so we can
keep moving through this this particular
idea
the paradoxes are that the lover on the
one hand seems to be encouraged in his
action of pursuing the beloved as a
matter of fact people and the legal
system as well will cut that person all
sorts of slack that they wouldn't do if
they were motivated by other things on
the other hand we see that there is a
kind of opprobrium attached to being the
one who is going to be the beloved the
one is going to in this case you know
we're talking about a relationship of
male male relationship in which you have
an older man who is the lover younger
man who is the beloved it's going to be
most likely you know a sexual
relationship at least you know at a
certain point where the male who is
older is going to be the active one the
male who is younger is going to be the
passive one and it's felt to be in some
respects shameful to submit to that it's
it's in a certain respect unmanly to to
be the passive one it is considered to
be you know manly to be the one who's
who's active so should the beloved
submit to the lover or should we allow
lovers to actually pursue and in some
respects you know impose something
shameful upon the beloved he brings up
the example of parents you know who say
you know I don't have a problem with
this in general but not with my kid and
so there's a paradox there there's an
ambivalence within the Athenian laws now
pause audience has a good explanation
for what's really at the bottom of this
he says at the resolution to these
paradoxes lies in understanding that
there's more than one kind of love more
than one kind of sexual attraction here
again in terms of good and bad but if
you looked at the previous video you
understand that he's talking about a
heavenly and an earthly or a you know
really we could say all good and
a mixed good and bad sort of love the
good love is you know coming from the
heavenly Aphrodite it knows what it's
doing it loves not just the person's
body so it's not just about the
superficial but the loves our
personality they're sold who they really
are it's it's one that can last through
through time because it's not based on
something that's going to fade away
right away the bad love is based on the
superficial and so why are these
paradoxes there because when we say the
word love we don't know which one we
need and we should in fact discourage
people from relationships that are
structured solely by the bad love
because you don't know how it's going to
turn out it could turn out good for them
maybe it's mutually beneficial and
there's lots of pleasure and nobody gets
hurt but there's no guarantees of that
and all we have to do is consult our own
experience we don't even have to think
about relationships where there's some
sort of age and balance or power
imbalance we can think of relationships
between equals and when they are just a
matter of people getting it on you know
jumping into bed hooking up as we say
nowadays a lot of times people do get
hurt and why do they get hurt because
they act as if they are being motivated
by this good love when really it's just
as random you know act of you know
involving themselves in intercourse
really nilly with with somebody just
because they have a good body they have
a nice face they you know make them
laugh at that moment in time or they're
drunk right we could talk about beer
goggles and their distorted effect and
producing what we call bad love here
usually around closing time sao paulo
science is saying this actually provides
us with a good way of understanding why
the athenian laws are so complex he says
that the law distinguishes to the lovers
the ones who are engaged in the act of
pursuing lovers that are to be
encouraged and lovers who are to be
avoided so which lovers are to be
encouraged and which are to be avoided
well that depends on the good and the
bad love turns on several factors he
lays out some some rules of thumb for us
time is a factor of this the younger
person the beloved the one who's being
pursued or perhaps seduced the one that
the older person is in love with should
not give in to them too quickly why
because if they do then there's a good
possibility that it's just this bad luck
and that bad love is not going to stay
in the test of time so you know it put
in you know much more contemporary terms
if you want to be sure whether the
person who's pursuing you really is
loving you with the right kind of love
for the right kind of reasons hold out
on them don't give it up right away make
them work for this I would say right the
motive he talks about various motives
that people you know give into this he
says you know it's immoral to give in
when the surrender is due to different
sorts of considerations financial
considerations he would not be for
prostitution or all the other things
that we don't call prostitution but
which really amount to prostitution
sleeping with somebody so they can give
you access you know to the to the party
sleeping with somebody because they have
a nice house a nice car nice boat
sleeping with somebody because they take
you out for fancy dinners all those
sorts of things would be financial
considerations political considerations
you know what he's talking about there
is being advanced so we might not just
think about this in political terms we
can think about this in social terms do
you sleep with somebody who is older
than you who you know really is
infatuated with you who is going to give
you a lead for a job or perhaps is going
to promote you within a company he would
say the wash would forbid that sort of
thing because that's just an example of
this bad merely bodily love unmanly fear
of ill-treatment if you're if you're
giving in just because you're worried
about somebody imposing force
upon you he says that's also shameful
and the law should keep that sort of
bullying essentially verging on rate not
verging on right but its rate from from
occurring he says if the youth fails to
show the contempt he should for any
advantage he may gain in pocket or
position why because in motives like
these we find nothing fixed or permanent
except perhaps the certainty that this
is not a noble friendship so what you
know what is supposed to be going on
here it's not just supposed to be about
having sex it's not just supposed to
even be about romance or the the feeling
good that comes with infatuation it's
supposed to be about something a bit
higher bit more honorable not just a bit
more honorable quite frankly much more
honorable and that is virtue he says
that if this sort of thing is going to
go on what the laws should allow is the
virtuous lover to pursue the youth who
through their connection through their
engagement over time through seeing
their example through marie MC to sort
of mentoring or teaching is going to
acquire virtue so that the younger
person submits for the sake of virtue
pause audience is in fact proposing a
restriction of the Athenian laws he's
saying there's too many loopholes too
many confusions that allow for lovers
who really shouldn't be involved with
younger people to to get involved with
them he doesn't want to go so far as you
know I owning a Persia and say ban it
all together not least because he wants
to get his own relationship with Agatha
do by now is a young man and their
relationship is going to continue
throughout their life as it is perhaps a
model of this sort of thing but he also
wants to say there are situations in
which this power imbalance this agent
balance could in fact be appropriate
we can't legislate without looking at
the characters of the people who are
involved if we do that we're going to
take one of these simple and
straightforward to too much too little
sort of resolutions and that won't be
good for anybody who's involved so
that's what's going on with all this
discussion of law in pisani is's speech